matt'll wide-ranging interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning it's with
the CEO of jewel the country's
top-selling east cigarette company he's
responding to the growing number of
breathing illness cases in people who
vape now the Centers for Disease Control
say it's looking into nearly 200
possible cases of severe lung disease
that may be tied to the use of
e-cigarettes the cases are reported
across at least 22 states now in his
first broadcast interview as jewel lab
CEO Kevin burns told us about his
concern it seems like every day we get a
new report from some health department
around the country saying that somebody
has severe lung failure severe lung
disease tied to vaping when that kind of
report pops up what's the reaction
worrisome worrisome for the category
were some for us if we contributed to it
CDC is leading the investigations we're
obviously in close contact with them so
our yeah they were working with that
we'd like to get there they're in charge
in the investigation we'd like to get
all the specifics that we can we want to
make sure we have access to the
information so if there's any issue that
was driven associated with us that we
can get to the root cause and understand
that why not take a pause why not say
we've got nearly 200 people hospitalized
with lung illnesses tied to vaping we're
the biggest seller of this stuff let's
just take a timeout till we figure out
what's going on well I don't know if
it's tied to vaping even associated with
nicotine products most of the early
reports have indicated it's related to
THC so I know that most but most of them
that have any specifics have said
they're related to THC we don't have the
details in all those reports if there
was any indication that there were an
adverse health condition related to our
product I think we'd take very swift
action associated with it so you feel
confident enough to keep selling despite
these reports that jewel is not
contributing to these more than a
hundred now a dozens of cases at this
point until we see some facts and the
CDC is leading the investigation yes we
do
that's Jul CEO Kevin burns he's very
confident in his product and what's
interesting is you know cigarettes
themselves were a tragedy in the 20th
century people are critical of jewell
because they don't want to see a second
tragedy with ISA Gretz his point of view
is if we don't give these cigarettes a
chance for
reduction to help smokers that could be
a tragedy in and of itself